en 86 vos parents achètent une maison à
Bobigny vous avez vécu vous avez grandi
dedans votre maman habitait seul juste
avant que le squat ne commence
non il y avait mon frère d'accord avec
elle alors votre maman avait des soucis
de santé enchaîner les allers-retours à
l'hôpital elle a toujours eu des soucis
de santé elle a toujours fait des
allers-retours en psychiatrie d'accord
un suivi
voilà et donc la maison était souvent
inoccupée votre frère il était où en
fait non mon frère était là il vivait
dans la maison en fait c'est un
appartement indépendant rez-de-chaussée
énervé son propre appartement d'accord
donc ils ont
la maison donc l'appartement était
inoccupé quand votre mère avait se
déplacer à l'hôpital c'est ça oui
forcément
là donc alors
profitons de ces absences répétées le 13
octobre 2021 votre maman subit une
première tentative de squat alors
qu'elle était à l'hôpital votre frère
habité encore à côté il était à côté
quand il y a eu cette tentative de squat
il était pas à côté il n'était pas là
mais il a dû passer un week-end d'une
saison mais il n'était pas présent dans
la maison était vide à ce moment-là
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont essayé de faire
pour rentrer ils ont essayé de rentrer
dans la dans l'appartement de notre
maman alors ils ont cassé donc le
portail d'accord sans rentrer avec la
force donc il y a derrière je sais pas
si on voit très bien sur la photo il y a
une porte en bois c'est on voit que
c'est une vieille maison quand même
donc c'est la porte du couloir c'est une
porte en bois et ensuite sur la gauche
donc à l'appartement de mon frère
et le reste de des étages c'était pour
ma mère en fait alors donc ils ont
pénétrés par infraction donc dans
l'appartement de votre maman là bien sûr
ce que je dise
personne qui nous regardent tous les
gens qui nous regardent et tous les gens
sur le plateau tout le public
il se passe quoi vous appelez la police
mon frère appelle la police alors non il
est rentré il a vu que la porte était
ouverte donc le cadenas était par terre
il est entré il les a vu il a vu que la
porte était ouverte donc il pensait tout
de suite que c'était des clandestins qui
étaient à côté
non non parce qu'on a déjà eu un
problème de squat par des personnes
auparavant et bon le secteur est pas
trop
un mal fréquenté on va dire il y a des
personnes qui recherchent du travail
dans les alentours donc il est rentré du
travail
[Musique]
c'est des personnes qui sont qui sont à
l'affût d'appartement qui serait laissé
de de exactement les personnes qui
connaissent extrêmement bien la loi
c'est ça quelques semaines après dans la
soirée du 31 octobre au 1er novembre
début de la trêve hivernale les
squatteurs reviennent mais cette fois
ils sont munis d'un faux bail de
location
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
alors quand ils sont arrivés le 13
octobre ils ont eu le temps sûrement de
fouiller dans les affaires de mon frère
dans ces la première fois qu'ils sont
venus des papiers
ou je pense que c'était le jour même il
a vu qu'il y avait des choses qui
avaient disparu d'accord donc enfin
c'est tous ces papiers il y avait des
papiers
donc il y a une plante qui a été déposée
et voilà donc ils sont revenus le 1er
novembre en prétextant la trêve
hivernale
et ce jour là ils n'ont pas été évincés
par la police
et donc
ils avaient les clés pour rentrer non
ils ont encore ils sont arrivés
le portable
donc il avait l'habitude de garer sa
voiture devant donc ils l'ont surveillé
ils ont attendu qu'il parte
à savoir la deuxième fois les deux amis
de mon frère se trouvaient dans le
grenier donc devant la télé enfin une
soirée entre amis les squatteurs sont
quand même rentrés je sais pas si ils
savaient qu'il y avait les amis de mon
frère qui se trouvaient là ils sont
rentrés et donc ils ont commencé à
menacer les amis de mon frère en disant
bah vous sortez
mon frère donc a été prévenu par ses
amis ils lui ont dit les mecs sont
revenus revient il y a les squatteurs
sont revenus donc mon frère il est
étonné il me dit mais de qui s'agit-il
les squatteurs les personnes de la
dernière fois donc mon frère dit ne
bougeait pas il y a tous mes affaires et
à tout j'appelle la police donc lui
pensait que la police allait aller faire
les choses correctement les sortir sauf
que non les squatteurs ont présenté un
bail un faux bail
avec donc la signature apparemment de
mon frère du coup ils ont dit à mon
frère bah trouvez-nous que vous êtes
bien aucune occupant ici
il n'avait pas de quoi prouver le titre
de propriété c'est moi qui l'emmène en
ma possession
étant donné que c'est moi qui m'occupe
de ma mère et que je suis sa curatrice
il pouvait pas il était enfin voilà
c'est ils lui ont dit vous partez vous
sortez il a dû laisser sa deuxième donc
sa deuxième voiture qui était dans la
cour et tout s'est bien à l'intérieur
tout le mobilier tous ses affaires il a
pris un sac il est parti ils ont dit
qu'ils disent qu'ils ont payé 3500 euros
pour habiter quelques pendant quelques
mois oui bah c'est fou c'est oui
ça c'est un prétexte en fait pour
pouvoir rester dans les lieux
quelques mois plus tard le 15 janvier
dernier vous vous rendez à la maison
occupé par les squatteurs avec les
membres d'une association l'objectif
c'était quoi vous lier les sortir oui
voilà donc
voilà c'est quoi c'est c'est des
personnes qui viennent en aide pour ce
genre de souci mais c'est des personnes
ça s'est passé c'était quoi c'était pour
les déloger Manu militarisme c'était
pour discuter avec eux oui pour c'est
plutôt musclé ou pas c'était musclé
parce que les squatteurs ne sont pas
laissés faire ils ne voulait pas sortir
ils ont été agressifs donc ils ont
refusé de sortir et donc qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé au moment où donc tout était
fini la police qui arrive donc tout
était fini c'est à dire vous les avez
sorti
on leur disait de sortir la femme était
déjà sortie ils étaient déjà en bas ils
étaient trois donc il y a quoi c'est
quoi ces deux garçons
c'était une femme un enfant et donc le
squatteur qui avait fait qui était là la
première fois d'accord il a refusé de
partir oui donc là forcément vous en
venez aux mains disait que c'était chez
lui qu'il avait un sortez de force ouais
c'est ça il est sorti
à moi mais oui voilà vous étiez combien
alors on était une trentaine
on était une trentaine et on a fini 23
en garde à vue d'accord c'est ça puisque
la police arrive et vous finissez en
garde à vue vous y restez combien de
temps en garde à vue à peu près deux
jours et demi un jour et nuit il y avait
la propriétaire il y avait donc ma mère
de 75 ans qui a aussi fait de la garde à
vue avec nous ça ça n'a pas été stipulé
sur les
sur les journaux
à savoir qu'elle n'avait pas son
traitement lors de la garde à vue
donc voilà donc je voulais vous donner
juste à 48 heures de garde à vue c'est
énorme
et donc 23 personnes placées en garde à
vue les squatteurs ont récupéré le
logement vous êtes libérés donc deux
jours plus tard le 17 janvier et là vous
décidez de faire quoi
d'attendre d'accord vous attendez de
faire des de continuer les procédures
auprès de la préfecture tout était
bouclés il voulait pas nous aider
donc on est passé enfin j'ai fait une
demande de tribunal avec l'aide de
l'aide juridictionnelle
et donc on a attendu notre de passer en
jugement et là gros
on était on s'y attendait vraiment pas
c'est la folie c'est incroyable
gilbertez vous êtes d'accord avec les
squatteurs alors ce sont des squats
et là vous êtes tombés sur des
squatteurs professionnels avec le bail
après bien sûr que c'est une violation
de domicile c'est une erreur et d'autre
part c'est violation de domicile que
vous avez fait plus quasiment violence
en réunion parce que vous êtes arrivés à
25 ça a failli dégénérer donc il peut y
avoir une très lourde condamnation je la
cautionne pas trois ans de prison 30000
euros d'amende violation de domicile et
ce qui est fou c'est que les squats
heureux ne risque qu'un an de prison
mais c'est ça c'est fou la loi on est
d'accord mais il faut pas déloger les
gens de force madame
qui est occupé par des squatteurs
la violation de domicile c'est forcé un
tiers à quitter le lieu où il habite
voilà c'est ça qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire alors
continuer les procédures de 3 mois
quel est le profil des squatteurs
c'est à dire le profil non mais c'est
quoi ils sont ils sont plus ils sont
trois ils sont 10 ils sont combien
maintenant ça change ils sont plutôt ça
change à chaque fois ça change c'est pas
les mêmes c'est pas les mêmes c'est pas
les mêmes à chaque fois donc le 13
octobre c'était pas les mêmes donc le 13
octobre il y avait deux femmes et de
deux hommes et le premier novembre il y
avait un enfant une femme et bah le
squatteur mais ça change entre temps il
y a eu des cousins du squatteur et donc
aujourd'hui on s'en est où
Airbnb
aujourd'hui j'ai récupéré la maison au
mois d'août dans un état lamentable
comment vous avez fait pour récupérer la
maison
je suis désolé parce que ça me fait mal
au cœur en fait de voir les images comme
ça et
j'ai pas
mis de pierre mais
ça c'est pas le pire non c'est pas le
pire on est resté sans portail pendant
longtemps
ma mère était obligée de rester dans la
maison parce que on avait peur en fait
d'être squatté bien sûr récemment elle a
eu encore une personne qui est venue
malgré qu'on avait posté le qu'on avait
mis le portail qui s'est introduit dans
la cour
et qui a cherché à avoir encore des
informations à savoir si ma mère était
seule dans la maison si les enfants
étaient là
les gens les gens deviennent fous je
comprends tout à fait les gens
deviennent fous
de France Inter je vous jure que c'est
vrai je dis pas ça
tu vas dire ils vont tu vas devenir tu
vas passer de victime à coupable et
c'est exactement ça je vous dis
aujourd'hui vous êtes passé de victimes
à coupable c'est ça et cette France des
bobos qu'on veut vraiment ici combattre
tous les jours je vous dis on n'en peux
plus c'est à cause de personnes comme ça
qu'on est dans des situations pareilles
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui
les lois sont faites d'une telle façon
que ça prend des années et des années
aujourd'hui vous avez eu la chance vous
de récupérer la maison au bout de
combien de temps au bout de presque un
an presque un an la maison dans un état
lamentable ça va vous coûter énormément
d'argent pour pour refaire la maison
pour comment vous l'avez fait pour
récupérer vous avez ma maman était en
train de
de faire un petit tronc à côté de la
maison il y a personne les portes
étaient par terre c'était complètement
ouvert elle m'a dit Sonia il y a
personne
vient on va ils sont partis ils ont mis
la maison dans un état lamentable ils
sont partis en fait la maison elle était
souvent vide des fois je passais moi
quand j'allais au travail et je voyais
qu'elle était en fait c'est des
squatteurs mais qui ne sont pas
forcément tout le temps là d'accord
c'est qu'avant lesquatteurs prenez des
des logements vides
éventuellement pour sortir sa maman pour
la mettre dehors et eux se mettre dedans
et après on va te dire non mais attends
on peut pas les sortir franchement bah
reste dehors toi reste dehors toi va
nous dire que c'est ça
des chroniques dans des radios qui me
dégoûtent non mais c'est vrai non mais
ils sont en train de [ __ ] la merde et
qui qui envoie la France dans le mur je
vous jure que c'est vrai ici horrible je
dirais toujours Baba contre les bobos
voilà c'est insupportable non mais je
vous le dis la France des bobos et la
France de Baba pour moi voilà enfin là
ce soir c'est c'est incroyable on marche
sur la tête les gens deviennent fou il y
a des gros problèmes dans ce pays mais
ça continue et on continue à à voilà à
courber les Chine et à attendre voilà
que que que que de drame des drames se
passent ils auraient pu avoir un drame
parce que imaginez que ça soit passé
vraiment
un je sais pas un domicile
on a été menacé par les squatteurs on a
été menacés
voilà il y en a un qui vous menace ça
part en bagarre euh voilà et c'est c'est
il se passera mais c'est vous qui allez
finir au trou voilà mais alors pour une
situation que dans laquelle vous n'avez
rien demandé c'est comme ce monsieur à
Roanne qui n'a rien demandé il est
tranquille avec ça sa femme et
tranquille chez lui en train de regarder
la télé c'est un mec qui vient qui a des
des attouchements sur sa petite fille et
c'est lui qui va se retrouver au trou et
le gars en plus le gars qui fait les
attouchements il
ose parce que le système il ose porter
plainte il imagait porter plainte contre
lui pour euh non mais
je vous dis c'est c'est pas que la
justice c'est aussi de nombreux médias
attention de nombreux médias qu'il y a
en force et qui font beaucoup beaucoup
de mal et ça ça me c'est mon combat du
moment où sachez-le et vraiment c'est
insupportable les petits voilà les
petits délateurs comme ça les petits
voilà les bobos qui qui foutent un
bordel monstre voilà merci en tout cas
bon si on peut vous aider sur la maison
on le fera en tout cas merci beaucoup
pour vous aider on va voir ce qu'on peut
faire pour vous aider à remettre la
maison dans un état digne pour vous et
pour votre maman voilà on va essayer de
faire le maximum je vais voir avec mes
équipes mais on va essayer de voir ce
qu'on peut faire d'accord merci merci en
tout cas
[Applaudissements]